foreign
G owner of apologies would fight Pizza
in polishing slice shops the pandemic
put um quite a bit of a hit on us we
fortunately had a slice shop that were
able to operate during a pandemic
because we had a takeout window but the
wood fireplace was more difficult and it
really hasn't recovered to the point of
pre-pandemic
thank you
uh you know I think these regulations
are typically come up with by people who
don't own businesses my understanding
was
um that it was you know to have better
air quality in New York City I was told
that
um by January of I think it was 2018
that I had to have one of these
scrubbers on on my pizza oven and I
comply it basically turns the smoke from
a wood fired or a coal fired oven into
steam I spent like twenty thousand
dollars doing that and I have to
continue to maintain it not only did I
have to purchase the machine I had to
have an engineer look at you know where
it could be installed I had to get an
electrician to run electric to it I had
to get a plumber to run a water line
because you have to have a hose to clean
it
the impact it's going to have is very
local like within the block that you're
at okay but even if a hundred
places have to put these things on
um that's not going to impact the
overall air quality in New York City
okay I mean it's just bizarre to think
that was fortunate enough that this
device was able to be installed where it
was installed and able to do that some
other people may have some constraints
there that don't allow them to do that
and and you know twenty thousand dollars
to some people you know could crush them
you know particularly since the pandemic
I just did a pre-pandemic and you know
it was a lot of money but right now
there's some people that barely keep
their doors up and if they have to do
this you know if you're going to make
their uh you know regulation maybe the
taxpayers should pay for it rather than
me I pay plenty of taxes already
if I was going to start a new Pizzeria
now it would not be a pizzeria that you
solid fuel like that it just it's just
too much trouble to do that based on the
regulations that that I put in place I
just wouldn't do that I opened up a
slice shop that uses I'm using an
electric oven there now it doesn't
produce any of that and that's what I'll
do in the future I wouldn't advise I
don't advise anybody to do it with a
wood fired Pizzeria anymore as you know
as romantic as it is you know I'd go in
a different direction because of the the
difficulties in dealing with that that
style of pizza you know requires that
kind of hot oven this technology that
can you know change that somewhat but
really to have it you know really I burn
my oven at a thousand degrees and it's
very difficult to emulate that plus part
of what
um makes our pizza cooked the way it
does is they have to cook with flame
there has to be an open flame over you
know the top of the Dome to cook that
pizza properly and when when you cook it
in a different kind of oven you won't
get the results that will produce a
Neapolitan style pizza you know New York
style pizza the ovens that are out there
now are incredible but it's just that
you know it's like it'll be a Dying
Breed people just are not going to deal
with this anymore
I mean we continue to
serve the same Quality Pizza we did
before but again somebody else that
could really crush them if it is
something that gives people pleasure in
life or in other cases a source of their
their income people people
should not want that to be negatively
impacted and and this is what's going on
I mean really you know are these
regulations that are being put in place
you know as my son likes to say all the
time is the juice worth the squeeze
about the tax payers pay for it now I'm
serious why you know why do I have to
spend twenty thousand dollars you know
I'm paying a ton of taxes already
and you know and and you know regulation
after regulation puts more pressure on
us and makes it difficult to you know do
business particularly now with you know
the course of Labor has gone up the cost
of you know the the goods that we you
know we have to buy to produce our
products you know and it's just making
it more difficult